for years there have been calls for more
diversity in the tech
industry a recent study shows little
progress
black professionals make up just five
percent of the tech workforce and
three percent of executive positions
carter evans introduces us to one tech
entrepreneur
tackling the industry's issues head on
if the tech town pipeline isn't working
we decided that we were going to rebuild
that pipeline
michael ellison knows firsthand how
difficult it is to break into the tech
industry
he grew up with a single mom in rural
maine and was homeless at times
but he excelled at math and was
encouraged to study computer science in
college
i was sitting in a classroom spending 30
hours to complete assignment that
kids standing next to me were taking say
two to four hours
i just felt like i wasn't smart enough
to major in cs he dropped out of the
program
after his freshman year if you're an
underrepresented minority
if you're coming from a low income
background the system's not designed for
you he says one of the main problems is
that underrepresented minorities are
more likely to attend computer science
programs
with outdated classes in limited
resources
ellison eventually got his degree and
worked with startups that focused on
tech education
one built a training program for
companies like facebook google and
netflix called codepath
and he realized it could also fill in
the gaps in college curricula
now students in 60 schools nationwide
can take courses on the industry's most
in-demand skills like app development
and cyber security
i wanted to be able to learn mobile
development for ios
because i feel like that's a great skill
to have today is a panel and we have
some people in the industry talking to
us
we just finished up with lab uh we
discussed
the assignment for this week and it
looks like we're going to build
a clone of instagram i think it's
looking pretty good
codepath also helps prepare students for
their first
tech job interview more than half of
those in the program are minority or
first generation college students
including 20 year old fazia alibiosu who
studies computer
science in maryland i was hooked i
really was because i learned about
android development which is something
my school doesn't have courses about
and i also got to like talk to people
who are already in industry like android
engineers
it's been so helpful to know what
companies are looking for
especially when you don't know any
computer sciences in your life
carter evans san francisco
ellison says a black computer science
student at codepath is 43 more times
more likely to be able to get a job at
one of the most competitive tech
companies